Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Bedirhan Cinar
Coral reefs are some of the most
spectacular ecosystems
on the planet.
They're also some of the most vulnerable.
But how can we protect the reefs
and the animals and plants
who rely on them?
And how can we make sure
our protected areas aren't hurting those
who use reefs to survive?
These are some of the big questions
facing marine conservation
biologists today.
Let's take Fiji, for example.
Fiji is series of islands
in the South Pacific Ocean.
To help balance the need
for conservation and making a living,
scientists had suggested
that instead of one big park
which provides a lot of coverage
for one reef system
while leaving the rest unprotected,
a better way is to create
a system of protected areas
nested together like pearls on a string.
This idea is called connectivity.
In this way, scientists can protect
lots of different habitats
while not excluding people
from their traditional fishing grounds.
Now, the only way this string-of-pearls
kind of reserve network is going to work
is if each park is connected
to other parks.
There are two main benefits to this.
First of all, insurance.
If something bad happens to one park,
say, an oil spill or coral bleaching,
then because that park
is part of a system,
it can be reseeded from other parks
that escaped the event.
The second benefit is representation.
By conserving many different areas,
scientists ensure that lots
of different habitats get protected.
This way, they can make sure
all the different marine habitats in Fiji,
such as coral reefs,
mangroves, and sea-grass beds,
are all represented.
This way, we don't unduly settle
any particular village or group of people
with the economic burden of having
their fishing grounds off-limits.
By sharing the cost
around the communities,
they can also share the benefits.
So if we agree
that rather than one big park,
we should have lots of parks
of different sizes
and covering different habitats,
then scientists need to make sure
those smaller parks are connected,
because if they're not,
they probably won't be self-sustaining.
But how do we know that?
That's where genetics and DNA come in.
By looking at how closely related
the fish in each one
of these small reserves in Fiji
are to each other,
scientists can figure out
how much migration is going on
among the reserves within the system.
Now it's important to look
at a variety of different species
because there's no guarantee
that what's going on with these guys
is what's going on with these guys.
But if we look closely
and at enough species,
we can see whether or not
the necklace is working.
What scientists have found
so far is that, in general,
there's a fair amount of connectivity
amongst the parks within Fiji.
But it's not just a big free-for-all;
rather, it seems that, for some species,
babies born in the far west
are having a hard time
making it to the islands in the far east.
To help deal with that,
conservation biologists are suggesting
that there be enough parks
in both the east and the west
to keep the populations healthy.
This isn't just in Fiji, either.
Lessons about reserve connectivity
can help across the world.
In places like Indonesia, Papua New Guinea
and the Bahamas,
scientists are using a variety
of tools to help understand
how individual parks
can function together,
so that their sum is greater
than their whole.
And this way, we can keep
the beautiful necklace
that is our coral reefs, intact.